it's great to welcome to the program
today Rutger Bregman who is a historian
and also author of humankind a hopeful
history and the best-selling utopia for
realist you may also recognize him from
such viral moments as that time he said
the thing about taxes at Davos and when
tucker carlson flipped out on him and
tried not to air it
Rutger great to have you on I appreciate
it thanks for having me David so to
begin with a hopeful history humankind
I'm interested in this because
particularly right now there are many
people who maybe don't have the most
optimistic perspective on humanity and
and on homo sapien so what what is your
source of general optimism about
humanity the book is really about a sort
of silent revolution that has taken
place in science within I'd say the last
15 to 20 years so what has happened is
that scientists from very diverse
disciplines anthropologists sociologists
psychologists you name it have moved
from maybe a little bit cynical view of
human nature to a much more positive
hopeful view of human nature so in the
book I'm just sort of describing this
whole process and trying to point this
out because what I discovered is that
often these scientists don't even know
it from each other right there was one
psychologist who at one point during my
research said to me when I told her
about you know stuff that's happening in
biology and she said oh my god it's
happening there as well so I just wanted
to to let people know that this has been
going on and it may be a source for hope
as well how do you make the case that
human beings are sort of fundamentally
good to the extent that that's a kind of
definable actionable term mmm-hmm well I
wouldn't say that people are
fundamentally good right we're we're
clearly not angels yes what I would say
is that what you assume in other people
is often what you get out of them right
so if you assume that most people are
selfish and you'll start designing your
institutions around that idea you know
your school's your marketplaces
everything you're doing your society
then that's what you get out of people
right so what you assume is what you get
I think this is actually the
vining idea of what we call
neoliberalism right which is basically
people are selfish and deal with it and
design everything around it I think it
has sort of produced the kind of people
that the theory presuppose and I think
we can turn it around and in the book I
try to give a lot of examples of for
example schools or or even organizations
or even prisons that work with this sort
of different kind of view of human
nature and then get some pretty
interesting results as well well that's
what's so interesting about it which is
as you point out if if you take an
economic perspective if you believe
people are fundamentally greedy you then
design an economic system around that
and it has major implications that are
difficult to undo even if people aren't
fundamentally greedy yeah if you look at
evolutionary psychology if you look at
so see all et cetera every one of the
systems we've designed is based around
some of these core ideas so the
implications are actually not just a
theoretical and trivial they're very
real it's a quite revolutionary idea so
it must at first it may sound like oh
this guy has written some nice happy
clappy book about how human beings are
friendly no actually the implications
are really revolutionary because you
know if we cannot trust each other then
we need them right to keep us in check
then we need the CEOs and managers and
the bankers and the monarchs and the
generals and you name it then we need
those empower them we need hierarchy if
actually most people are pretty decent
and can be trusted then we can move to a
radically different society you know
that is much more egalitarian where
people have the freedom to make their
own choices
suddenly all kinds of things become
possible that initially we're not
possible at all at what sort of level of
focus do you think is the right one to
make these observations about humanity
and I'll give you an example of what I
mean you could take for example the
kitty Genovese II a story of 1964 and
the bystander effect and use that to
extrapolate about you
nature or you could say hey you know
what over time war has become less and
less common you're right these are very
different levels of focus when you may
get you to different conclusions about
human nature where do you think we
should start evaluating what human
nature is well I think you need to look
old these things and the book I start
with a very old theory within Western
culture which is the idea of veneer
theory right and the idea goes like this
supposedly civilization is only a thin
veneer and as soon as something happens
say a war or a natural disaster or you
shipwreck on an island then supposedly
people reveal their true selves and you
know they show that they're really
animals and they're selfish if you look
for example the news coverage of natural
disasters it's pretty much always like
this it's always veneer theory you know
the news is full of stories about
looting and violence and plunder you
know kind of all kinds of horrible
stories but actually what sociologists
have known basically since the 1960s is
that what you get every single time
after a natural disaster is an explosion
of cooperation people are really working
together a great example is what
happened after Katrina in the u.s.
Rebecca Solnit has written a fantastic
book about this a paradise built in Hell
but there are many other examples around
the globe so it's really the opposite of
venire theory but still this theory is
so deeply entrenched in our culture you
know the idea that deep down were all
selfish it goes back all the way to the
ancient Greeks you find it with the
Christian Church Fathers you know the
idea that we're all born as sinners even
the enlightenment philosophers David
Hume Adam Smith I think you could argue
that the u.s. itself was sort of founded
on the idea that people are selfish if
you read some of the texts of the
founding fathers John Adams for example
he wrote an essay that said all men
would be tyrants if they could or James
Madison who said you know ambition must
be made to counteract ambition you know
let's let's be real let's assume that
most people are selfish so often when
people say oh you've got to be a realist
they say well don't be too idealistic
right otherwise you're naive and so I
think that the larger product project
here is sort of
to try and redefine what it means to be
a realist is that actually the realistic
scientific position these days is to
sort of conclude that actually human
beings have evolved to cooperate and
there's actually this process in our
evolutionary history that biologists
call survival of the friendliest which
is very much the opposite of what I had
always thought what role in this
analysis does the idea of a sort of
multi-layer evolutionary selection have
to play the idea that an individual
being greedy within a group that
cooperates may may be a more relevant
way to look than simply humans are
individually greedy or not greedy well
there are certainly different theories
right now within biology right whether
you should look at evolution on the
individual level or under group level
and there's a lot of scientific debate
going on there and to be honest I don't
really have a big position here I think
sort of the more important takeaway of
you know developments within biology of
the past couple of years say 15 to 20
years is that actually biologists have
discovered this process of what they
call survival of the friendliest right
so for thousands of years it was
actually the friendliest among us who
had the most kids you know imagine
Donald Trump in prehistory it's an
impossibility you know he wouldn't have
survived for long people wouldn't have
liked him wouldn't want to cooperate
with him
I would have expelled him from the group
and probably would have died alone right
or if he was really nasty would have
been executed by the group so we know
this from you know studies from nomadic
hunter-gatherer tribes around the globe
that being friendly being humble was
really a prerequisite if you wanted to
survive now it's only recently in this
era that we call sort of the civilized
era that everything has changed and
nowadays you know there seems to be this
process that we call survival to shame
this right we're so often if you are
shameless that can actually be an
advantage which is I think highly
unnatural for us as a species because
you know one of the most fascinating
things that I discovered during my
research is that human beings are
actually the only species in the animal
kingdom that blush you know which is a
fascinating fact that we blush and for
thousands of years it was an
evolutionary advantage for us because it
helped us to cooperate and I think we
need to go back to that vision of human
nature so I want to ask about what your
vision of human nature would imply maybe
the economic system should be but before
we get to that the venire theory is it
too early to see if or how that applies
to the world reaction to coronavirus or
or do you have some sense of if and how
that applies to how we're currently
seeing the world react to that pandemic
mm-hmm well obviously at first there
were some stories or quite a lot of
stories in the press about people
hoarding toilet paper and you know why
even fighting over toilet paper and
again it was very tempting to conclude
that oh here we have a crisis people are
selfish once again I think by now we can
zoom out and and say that actually the
vast majority of most people has
actually been pro-social nature most
people are actually helping each other
there's quite some evidence accumulating
now from different countries is that you
know it mostly brings out the positive
that the good in people you know there's
so many initiatives from the bottom up
you know groups on whatsapp and on
Facebook and neighbors helping each
other etc etc and this is all not very
surprising to sociologists because as I
said you know they've known for a very
long time that most people pull together
during a time of crisis it's not it's
not what the Hollywood movies have
taught you you know it's not like panic
and everyone going nuts and crazy blow
up that's very much the opposite you
know one of the most striking eyewitness
accounts that I discovered during my
research was for example how some people
behave during 9/11 you know when they
were going down the stairs of the Twin
Tower Twin Towers as they were burning
and people were literally saying no you
go first no you go first no yeah this is
crazy but it actually happened so you
talked about how seeing human nature as
fundamentally greedy implies or maybe
justifies the neoliberal
economic framework which is very
interesting if someone were to accept
your fundamental view of human nature
what is the economic system that would
logically follow from that hmm well you
can do a lot of things actually I
started writing this book because I had
first written a book about the idea of
giving everyone a guaranteed basic
income right so what this was utopia
free Atlas and the book was full of
studies and examples and experiments
that show that this could actually work
people in general have sort of two
objections against the idea and they say
well it doesn't work because you know
people are lazy and they'll stop working
or they'll say you can't do it because
people will waste the money you know
they'll just spend it on drugs or
alcohol this is like the two most common
objections and so I sort of tried to
collect all this evidence and say you
know it actually just worked we have
tried it and the the science says it
works so I went on a book tour in a
couple of countries and again and again
and again I found myself discussing
human nature with people because so much
so often people would say yeah okay
maybe this works on a local level maybe
this works in this particular experiment
here or there in Canada or in the u.s.
in the 70s but that was a very different
place highly exceptional in the end you
just got a look at human nature and be
realistic so I started to understand
that for so many of the exciting ideas
that I cared about and not only basic
income but also for example different
ways to do democracy you know
participatory democracy they all
presuppose a different view a more
hopeful view of human nature and then I
realized that actually I didn't have
that view myself you know I had studied
history I had you know studied so many
of these sort of cynical experiments
from the 60s to stanford prison
experiment or the Milgram experiment
that many people will know with the
shock machine so I started basically on
a journey whether basically to see if I
if I could actually realistically adopt
a more hopeful view of human nature and
that resulted in this book and is there
a specific I mean from the point of view
of the the vast majority of so-called
Western democracies
or is there low-hanging fruit or
so-called specific policies that would
be the ones that most obviously could be
changed for the betterment of society on
the basis of your newfound optimism oh
well maybe it's interesting to zoom in
on prisons mm which is one of the most
radical applications of this theory of
human nature if you go to Norway you'll
find prisons that are really really
weird and strange where they really
treat inmates as if they're actually
people so there are prisons like bus toy
or Halden very close to Oslo where
you'll find you know people who have
been convicted of murders or rapes or
pretty horrible things but still get the
freedom you know to read books there's a
cinema there's even a music studio they
have their own music label that it's
called criminal records and and you
would Eve you know some people would say
well this is like some kind of holiday
resort but then you look at the science
behind it right you look at the
statistics and in particularly you look
at the recidivism rate and you realize
that actually Norway has the lowest
recidivism rate in the world so the
chance that someone will commit another
crime you know officer he or she gets
out of prison that's the recidivism rate
is nowhere as low as in Norway so these
prisons work even though they don't
really look like prisons they're highly
highly effective then you look at
prisons in the US and you realize that
actually these prisons have have the
highest recidivism rate in the wall
right if you treat people like crap
there will be crap I think I can't make
it easier than that if you treat people
like people that will behave like people
this in the case of prisons it really
goes against your intuition right you
really sort of the intuition says
vengeance you know people who have done
these horrible things you want vengeance
you want to lock them up you want them
to suffer but if you realistically look
at what works then I think Norway really
leads the way here yeah it's also
counterintuitive one one might imagine
you want prison to be really bad so
people are more incentivized to avoid
going back
just does not seem to actually function
function in that way obviously and the
other problem is that prisons can become
sort of universities for crime so this
is really the case in the u.s. people
people come in maybe for a small minor
offenses drug offenses or something like
that and then they become hardened
criminals in the prison system right I
for the book I looked at the history of
the of the system in the US and it's
it's really astonishing to find out that
actually in the early 70s you know the
u.s. experiments that with Norway style
prisons you know and it worked really
well it's just that after that history
took a different direction same is true
for basic income by the way the u.s.
almost implemented a guaranteed basic
income under Nixon you know there's no
country that came as close to
implementing a basic income as the US
for that didn't happen in the end
notice of a lot of bizarre coincidence
yeah even I mean between World War one
and two there was a moment where the
direction for health care in the United
States was going towards universal
health care but it was deemed to be too
much like what was happening in Germany
at the time and for political reasons
that it was not pursued as we of course
of course now now we've been speaking
with Rutger Bregman historian author of
humankind a hopeful history and of
course author of the best-selling utopia
for realists I so appreciate your time
today thank you thank you